hi everyone a motherfucking bossy senior
director of education and international
initiatives at film independent well
non-profit film arts organization based
in Los Angeles but with members
worldwide our mission is to champion
creative independence in visual
storytelling and support a community of
artists who embody diversity innovation
and uniqueness efficient today I'm
joined by two artists with me on decent
chat is multi-talented actor
screenwriter director Casey Limits
whose incredible list of credits include
Harriet black Nativity talk to me Camus
Valentine and it's Bayou which one a
Spirit Award for Best Feature and it's
part of the National Film registry he
also happens to be a very committed
board member of them independent he
thank you so much for everything you do
for us Casey joining her he's also
Nicole Jefferson Asher who has extensive
credits writing for film and television
having created projects for Fox Warner
Brothers HBO and many others and her
recent credits include love beeps rhymes
for Lionsgate and selfmade inspired by
the life of mud and CJ Walker for
Netflix
she's a filming dependent fellow having
participated in several over artist
development programs I have known them
for almost I'm not gonna say how many
years expose in any way but I saw the :
Casey have collaborated on self-made
starring obtain iya Spencer and an
incredible cast including blur
Derwood Tiffany Haddish I'm Carmen
jugga-jugga which premiered Netflix on
March 20th and thanks God because that
was the weekend we went on lockdown and
I watched said I don't like y'all there
got worke there was some kind of like
feeling of yeah we weekend person here
so thank you so much it was really
inspiring and congratulations and
welcome for you to agreeing to join us
today first I'm gonna get a start by
addressing the big elephant in the room
how are you guys doing in these Kobe
epidemic
Casey you're a New York or cluster New
York are you working how are you feeling
about all of this
I'm on Cape Cod which is our family home
we left to come for spring break when I
took spring break from school at NYU
we were planning to come here for spring
break anyway and then we just never went
back and so I've been teaching from here
and um you know I don't know exactly
when I'm gonna get back to New York I
miss it oh my god how's the teaching
going I mean it's it's weird you know
it's good yeah yeah I know a lot about
soon okay what about me call you you're
here in LA I know a but how are you
feeling about all these and are you
working yes I'm actually in a virtual
room I'm doing a TV show for Showtime
called first ladies it's in the
anthology series about first the first
ladies of the United States our first
season is Michelle Obama Eleanor
Roosevelt and Betty Ford so every day we
you know I'm on zoom' all day it's and
it's been it's been challenging you know
I mean look I'm grateful to be working
I'm grateful to be healthy I'm grateful
to be safe
I'm grateful to be able to you know be
in a safe environment
so you know that right there you know
I'm not going to complain about zoom but
you know it's certainly it's definitely
challenging you know I think you know be
you know the whole point of setting up a
writers room is so that people could
work collaboratively that people can you
know hash out ideas people can you know
you know put all of your ideas I'm gonna
board and look at stare at them all day
and and so a lot of so a lot of the
things that really lend themselves to
you know being in a writers room we
don't have particularly our story is
very nonlinear so it's it's really
difficult to track but again I mean I
think but you know it also at the same
time you know we're we're committed to
you know really trying to you know make
the best show possible so I think that
you know sometimes at adversity makes
you work harder so you know and
certainly that's what I've seen because
I've dealt with a lot of adversity but
you know it's it's not ideal but it's
it's certainly I'm grateful to be a
writer at this time you know and I and I
sympathize with the other collaborators
in our industry who are out of work and
you know the future is very uncertain I
know so so do you hang now don't unseal
the whole day notes that work like the
amount of time you would spend on a
virus on your own sue mm-hmm
I can't imagine you know a lot of in
soon but I'm like soon doubt by the end
of the day yeah it's it's more tiring
don't you find yes absolutely and I yeah
I'm even putting my classes but it's
just like a and um and I think that
we're having a good experience but at
the same time it's it's a little bit
more it takes more out of you it feels
like absolutely I mean and I think that
also it keeps me from keeping more in
touch with people because I've spent six
hours a day talking and sitting in one
chair and so you know that's it's
literally the last thing I want to do so
I'm also
but it's it's very it's draining in a
way that you know interacting with with
people alive it's not so I'm even more
grateful that you are here with us we
call thank you so much
so let's get to to dressed I mean let's
start with it the journey of the project
actually and where did you first find
out about this incredible woman I mean
personally I had not heard about her and
sorry to find out about her
CJ Walker I mean she was the daughter of
slaves and and somehow she told herself
I'm able to do whatever I want done
became the first self-made millionaire
leave it so people that didn't know her
story could that's great so when did you
find out about her when did the two of
you first heard about her and and I mean
she's such a role model for any woman I
think I wanted to make something about
madam CJ Walker for about 20 years I've
been telling my aging you know I really
want to do something on madam CJ Walker
and um you know as time went by and I
kind of you know would would fall in and
out of this this desire to do it and
then Aliyah bundles wrote her book and I
spoke with her at a certain point about
the book and you know my passion for
this story and then schedules you know I
was working and I I couldn't get on it
and then the next I heard of it they
were on the holders were doing it with
Nicole and and Nicole and I go way back
yeah yeah Casey was interested in the
story and at that point
octavia the holders the first thing they
did was they attached
Octavia to play her so you know Octavia
in a lot of way you know hired us and I
remember you know one of our our first
conversations and three of us I mean you
know Casey and I go way back and I knew
she was interested in the story so it
was like come on you want to do this and
then when we met with Octavia
it was so great because we spent most of
the conversation just talking about hair
character in this movie and and talking
about you know our first rep my first
recollection of her was you know getting
my hair done on Sunday Saturday mornings
and my mom telling me you know pressing
my hair with a phone and saying madam CJ
Walker
you know invented the hot comb and you
know we all shared stories about that
and you know it was probably the one of
the less traditional kind of business
meetings I've ever had because we we
really talked about you know black
culture and and and hair and beauty and
black women womanhood and nostalgia and
and why her story hasn't been told and
and so I think it's you know I think
that is the spirit in which we made the
project
that's a funny that your that your
mother was like she had been at the hot
comb so a backside that precedes that
curling iron I mean that's kind of the
basis of right now I would say it's it
was they were created at the same time a
man in France said it said the Marcel
waves and you know he invented the
curling iron and they were originally
created for white women you know I mean
it wasn't created in Europe and so it
was it wasn't necessarily optimal you
know madam CJ Walker kind of optimized
it for black hair and you know she
really she she was an innovator of
products that already existed and she
had you know amazing marketing savvy and
and also really created a distribution
model you know most people that were in
you know in the very early hair care
industry were just kind of you know
making stuff in their homes
you know homemade you know doing their
their girlfriends hair or their mama's
hair but you know madam CJ Walker was
like I'm gonna build build a factory and
I'm going to make sure that my product
gets to every black woman on the
that's great so the book the book came
out what here and when they get to you
Nicole
when was the book published about twenty
years ago it got I I the holders gave it
to me about three years ago okay okay
and then you in Casey started
collaborating did you collaborate with
Lila as well or was she part of the
development process with you guys
absolutely I mean you know once we had
scripts we gave them you know we we had
some initial conversations with her and
certainly we use the book there but you
know the book is we we use the book as a
launching point you know certainly there
are many fictionalized characters
there's a you know a kind of a magic
realist interstitial you know that none
of that is in the book you know the book
is that you know the factual
documentation of Madame CJ's life so I
mean it's certainly that's why it's
inspired by the life of madam CJ is in
the title but you know once we you know
had scripts then Lily read every one and
gave us notes and you know gave us her
thoughts and you know and certainly
shared a lot of you know as Madame CJ's
main archivist she has access to a lot
of resources and a lot of information
and even furniture and pictures and
things like that
she was so did you and Casey collaborate
on their scripts or was there like the
proper writers room how those were well
how would those quits developed there's
a red is when we collaborated on the
pitch a bit you know but it was really
this was Nicole's you know Nicole
created the show and and so really after
we we had kind of developed a bitch
together and then we pitched it to
Netflix and they bit you know I was off
doing Harriet
and there was a whole writers room going
on so I kind of came off the movie and
there were scripts all right genetics
what did you take for a bitch at Netflix
I'm sure a lot of filmmakers are all
wanting to know how that that does that
go what do you have what did you take
how was that patient and what was the
reception
well we took that Tavia Spencer and
LeBron James I mean you know when the
holders approached me about the
adaptation at what I pitch to them was
doing a non-traditional biopic and to
use you know the the idea that madam CJ
Walker was a woman ahead of her time and
she and I wanted to use
like I said magic realism and
interstitials and all kinds of different
things to really show that she was a
visionary that she thought differently
that she saw the world differently
and you know and to be able to
communicate that on a really core craft
level as opposed to just saying it or
you know or making speeches about it so
that would that kind of that was part of
that was the initial concept and that
was share the whole just happened to
have a meaning with Spring Hill
entertainment and with LeBrons company
and not even really they just told about
the project they didn't really go to
them to be involved and they were like
oh we want to be involved and they're
like no no no no we really want to be
involved and so so that you know that
then they came on board and and you know
developed the pitch more and you know
mean Casey fleshed it out and you know
you know we pitched it to a few places
and and Netflix really just felt like
the best home that they got it that they
were very excited about the idea of
doing a historical figure from kind of a
very contemporary point of view and and
really we're excited about telling madam
CJ what her story that's great so how
did you land in in the right in in the
light right format was this ever like
was ever conceived as a feature as a
limited TV series a longer format
ten shows right it was you know it
honestly it came down it was pitched as
a limited series and you know the it
really the budget kind of dictated four
episodes budget and scheduling also too
you know so it it was it was a
roundabout process you know for that
that you know and it had there was a lot
of things involved but but I will say
that I think that four episodes is a
really interesting exciting length that
I'm glad is really starting to become a
thing you know when they see us for
episode you know there's you know
there's more programs like that and I
think especially for telling a
biographical story you know it gives you
more freedom than just a two-hour movie
you know most people's lives are very
difficult to kind of capture in and just
a two hour movie and you know and
sometimes ten hours is too much so I
think you know it had its challenges but
I do think that four hours is is you
know it I think that's going to be a new
kind of format that we see more of in
the future remember was a you never
wrote it as a feature at all so you had
to do some condensing of a lot of things
so what the process appointee like the
right balance between the personal and
the historic context of the times I mean
she's such an aspiring it's an expensive
character and you covers some of the
historic that you stay more I believe on
the personal so how did you said to do
that what questions were you asking
yourself all the time on what would stay
on the story and what would have to go
for you be able to compress it and still
we made some of the contacts that stay
with her yeah I mean it was it was
always you know it was always her story
it was always her point of view
it was you know that was very important
to me I think you know net we're just
now starting to see more programming
that is you know very solidly from a
black female point of view and
particularly because madam CJ's Walker
story has been you know really you know
is long overdue for a telling or her
cinematic exploration you know it was
really important to to keep to stay that
way I think that was really challenging
though was there were so many
interesting things in her life and she
had such a big life I mean you know we
didn't I mean I kind of feel like we
barely scratched the surface there was
so much philanthropic endeavors and her
child to you know that we just didn't
have the time to cover so but but really
what it came down to was people know her
as she's the first self-made female
millionaire in the United States you
know white or black or any color and so
what was really important was to show
how that happened how did she you know
create her product how did she create
her business and how did she become a
millionaire so that was really the the
lens that would you know in the the
filter that we kind of narrowed it down
but I mean it was it was hard it was
very hard I mean I had an interesting
life such an expensive story so Casey up
you have directed a ton of features you
have directed very few television right
so well how was this different for you
and and and how was you know the vision
conceived and communicated and and how
was working in the looing that that
mission with another director I
understand you work with um it was it
was interesting um I knew I mean
developing it with Nicole and and being
kind of in service of Nicole's vision
was um you know it was a great pleasure
because Nicole and I go way back and we
we collaborated together before and you
know I really trust her and
I trusted her storytelling and her
instincts for the story and um you know
when you come on to a show like this as
a director even though I was attached
from the beginning you know I understood
it to be
Nicole's vision at the same time being
the be the pilot director because even
um even in the four episode you know
there's a pilot then I was responsible
for setting the tone and the look of the
show you know so um so I had a lot of
responsibility that way and um it was
great I mean it was a wonderful group of
people wonderful women can I say you
know it was amazing and I had just come
from a movie that had been run by women
but this was on self-made we have women
in so many key positions that we would
have movies every key position so we
would have meetings and there would be
no men in the room you know I mean I've
never experienced that before where you
know the production designer and the DP
and you know hair and wardrobe then
everybody you know we were all women so
that was kind of my great pleasure and
then domain was the you know I was the
the director executive producer and
domain was the producing director so
we've got to work together through the
whole thing to kind of um shape it with
the showrunners and and and Nicole and
our producers and you know it was it was
definitely a collaborative effort and
that's um in a different way than a
movie is you know but I I really enjoyed
it and just to get to work with this
group of people in this cast you know it
was so it was such a pleasure would you
be glad to do more TV now that you have
been spoiled with your collaborators
yeah I definitely would I'm definitely
open to it
actually the visual language is
beautiful everything works together so
beautifully and I was telling Nicole
when she got in her background looks
like it belongs so you know as you were
talking about making it contemporary
about her forward
thinking and everything falling into
that I have a question about the music
which I noticed you know this
combination between very traditional
scoring and some jazz and then these
kind of very contemporary songs does
that reflect it's a reflection of that
choice that you made in the beginning to
make it more contemporary and
forward-looking because yes you know the
we we definitely and we had a first of
all we had a fantastic music supervisor
Morgan Rhodes and you know in the
meeting you know
in her interview I mean one of the
things that we both had kind of talked
about was was do you know creating a
unique sonic landscape that was big like
basically completely filled with black
female voices so we used all female
black female singers from around the
world and across every genre of music
and you know again to kind of you know
build the bridge that you know I mean
madam CJ Walker one of the reasons why
you know people love the show is because
her story is still relevant to us today
and relevant to so many people around
the world and so music was one of the
ways that we really tried to build that
bridge and fill that out and she did an
amazing job of finding voices also that
haven't been overused or that you know
like that you know sounds that we that
are familiar but you know different
somehow or a becoming artists and and
music from the past I mean so it was
that was really one of the high points
of working on the show was was creating
that and actually we have a Spotify
playlist if could we find it it's that's
that's wonderful so I you know I'm very
drink about her daughter Lidia and I'm
just
the woman who wrote the book beside her
granddaughter right and you know her
artistic playful queer sensibility was
that in the biography well you know it's
interesting because it's she yes it's
it's in the biography but not you know
certainly not it not to the extent that
we we conceptualized it I mean look you
know - Lily Walker was called was dubbed
by Langston Hughes as the joy goddess of
the Harlem Renaissance and to me you
know first of all if you think about the
Harlem Renaissance and you think about
all of the amazing personalities and
characters if she was the joy goddess
then you know I mean like then she must
have been out of control and so that to
me was one of the foremost character
traits that I you know was thinking of
in creating her character was that this
was a woman who was you know in in the
20s was very very rich you know in a
time when women couldn't vote when Jim
Crow was you know part of you know was
the you know national law when there
were so many things strikes against
black people she was living you know she
was the joy so the next project I'm
sorry that was right yeah it's a great
story and and so I think that you know
it was it was really important also I
think to show that she was not the same
woman as madam CJ and that actually that
was part of you know their difficulties
that you know that part of what madam CJ
worked so hard to do was give her a
better life and she was able to do that
and then she ended up being a very
different person from madam CJ Walker
and then on the end I think in a lot of
ways they had a hard time understanding
one another isn't it very different
okay so here's we're running a little
bit out of time but I want to get to
all of questions here a question for
Nicole could you talk about it more
about first ladies you will each episode
focus on a different first lady or they
intercut with within an episode as any
casting being announced the world wants
to know who is playing Michelle Obama I
can say that but it has been announced
actually it's on deadline so Viola Davis
is playing and probably the only other
thing that I can say is actually the
each episode will feature all three
women intercut so it's it's kind of
similar to the hours people remember
that movie or it's you know we we
juxtapose all of their lives kind of
thematic Lee throughout the yeah each
episode so watch for bid 20 everyday so
you know there's another question which
actually it's kind of the same questions
the same question where I really wanted
to end which is you know I want to talk
a little bit about my damn CJ Walker not
only as a role model of for girls and
women to encourage them to believe that
they're able to whatever they want but
also as a mentor and philanthropist you
know this idea of mentorship and women
empowering each other and lifting other
women up with them so you you both have
experienced being mentors and or being
mentored can you talk about that Casey
you have been forever like I began my
job for a long time I don't know Paul I
needed a good mentor can you talk a
little about that and then you and
Nicole can you address that - yeah I
mean I've been doing it a really long
time and I've had some time to kind of
think about it and reflect on it as as
I've as I've worked with seeing these
women like
Cole you know come into their full power
and have incredible careers and to have
been a part of that in any small way
just in terms of like giving advice or
encouragement or you know whatever I
could do I've really been able to see
kind of the fruits of that labor really
pay off as madam CJ Walker did you know
that that's it's the best feeling in the
world it's my own it's my way of
approaching the revolution honestly it's
my way of it's my way of helping to fix
the problem that exists in Hollywood you
know this incredible disparity um where
you know as everyone knows they're just
not that when many women working they're
ridiculously disproportionate to to who
we are and our presence in this in this
country and you know half of all people
or women directors right and that makes
no sense and then women of color which
is which has kind of been my my
specialty and it's it's very empowering
and it keeps me optimistic and here's
part of the question that I did not ask
actually is any notable mentors for you
did you have any mentors that you could
kind of like remembered what you're
doing for others right now that you look
up to not I mean you know I've been at
it so long and when I got in it um you
know there just weren't that many people
doing I can I can jump in there because
Casey was my greatest mentor and I mean
I'm forever grateful to her and you know
and I and I'm so glad that that you that
you know I think mentoring is important
because it really shows you all of the
things that you can't learn from film
school that you can't learn from a book
I mean I think one of the greatest gifts
and lessons that Casey gave to me was
just how to be a woman of integrity in
this business just to how to
how you know how to even beyond the
basics of taking meetings or any of that
but just you know how to make good
choices how to treat people fairly how
to how to be true to yourself how to be
true to your your visions and you know
it's it's incredibly difficult business
especially if you don't have come from a
background where you know you've been in
the industry or have you know a lot of
support systems as you know many women
and people of color don't so I mean it's
it's hugely important and I think I mean
it it made all the difference in my
career to be able to be able to you know
watch someone and to ask questions and
to be able to you know have somebody to
look up to you and you know so again I
mean I try to do that as much as
possible as well and it's I think we all
need to do that I mean we you know I
think we need Mentors and not just in
this business but just in in life you
know it's it's a really under under
developed you know skill set in our
culture and and it's you know I think
you can see them the results of it you
know people are running around lost you
know you say that the call is so much
more meaningful and beautiful that the
two of you have collaborated in this
project you know it's like the perfect
way of ending as you know some in
depending is all about this building
these bridges between mentors and and
helping each other I want to thank you
both for sharing your experience with us
today and always as you do in these and
I want to thank everybody in the virtual
room for joining us today
we at film independence are working
tirelessly to bring you closer and
continue our job building community
during these hard times and to find more
about upcoming programming please visit
so many dependent that org or follow us
on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram and thank you
bye-bye DeMaria
bye bye Thank You Maria bungeeclub right
[Music]